fantasy starting five is it tough is
this a three potato ball first thing my
teammate said and look at your phone I
looked at it notification calling crazy
from we've done shouldn't a point guard
go on first and then be a draft
[Music]
I'm back on the road and this time I'm
stopping in Florida to meet John Marant
this point guard from Murray State has
made a ton of noise on college
basketball both on and off the court
with the draft approaching he lets us in
on how he's preparing for the NBA all
right John Marant you went from being
barely recruited to a potential top 3
draft pick so when was the moment that
you said hey I'm I'm famous now
Oh Alabama game we came up short but I
think I finished through like 38 and how
to dunk that went viral getting on the
bus after the game first thing my team
they said it man look at your phone I
looked at it notification crazy from the
dog now I know after your NCAA
tournament win you gained about 100,000
followers on Instagram right how did
that feel it felt good but honestly I
think the win first time getting the win
it's so great but of those follows which
were the coolest
I filed levitator plans and NBA Kevin
Durant Luka college or one that's hardly
stand out right now and I was somebody
and I kind of grew up watching looking
at it followed me at the Envy island I
was in DMD yeah what'd he say he was
just like oh just keep working and
basically telling me that I was very
excited well I have another message for
you I told CJ McCollum that I was going
to be interviewing you and he sent a
video for me to show you
hey Kyle Taylor I heard you guy wanted
to be major killers coming in town this
week so I wish you nothing but the best
at the next level understanding you have
a responsibility
I'm a major program man be a monster we
get killer because Savage
don't lose your chip you know how you
play will affect the next job of all
affecting their CJ it will affect the
next thing the next step so keep that
pipeline open wish you nothing but
success except for when we play against
this but so he talks about just this
responsibility that you now have making
it from a mid-major is that how you feel
that the way that you play is going to
be the way we perceive mid-major players
coming for it yeah I think those guys CJ
dam and still kind of open it up for
some other major players and most of
them probably have the same story I'm
falling under the radar and end up
blowing up late and not everybody's like
who is this guy and all three of those
guys now with big-time players in the
NBA and hopefully when I get there I can
be one of those players with the draft
coming up lots of decisions to be made
with your suit what kind of statement do
you want to make with what you wear on
draft night I'm a fashion guy I like
dressing I love shoes I'm gonna be
different okay since you're a fashion
guy I'll show you some suits you give me
your thoughts that you grade the suit
LeBron come on bro I don't know what
color that is honestly this is like my
wrist probably can fit in there too
that's got to go with a seat only a seat
yeah cuz he's brought Damian Lillard I
just like how he throw it off a little
bit have the different color but at all
and sync together
that's a aw yeah all right Steph yeah
that's a yike yeah I don't know about
the color I feel a little big to I know
it's not
again good stuff
are you gonna see you get to see ya try
yeah it's different I think he should
have pulled it up a little bit like it
look like capris almost C+ and what do
you think of that they will know your
name
new jacket that's tough basically like
he trying to prove himself if there was
a message that you could put in a suit
what would your message be beneath no
one that's what my mom always told me I
probably would have that train to go to
that like basically I was built for this
moment so beneath no one and trained to
go yeah this right here this crazy IMG
me being able to work out here with all
this stuff so what's your goal while
you're training here at the IMG Academy
I say the biggest is probably getting
stronger the physicality in the NBA is
different than college and also public
conditions obviously I probably playing
50 plus more games and I did in college
just to be in the best shape I can be
for those 82 games
you also do some yoga here have you
benefited from the zen of yoga yeah my
body was a little tight and we actually
did yoga a little bit before the season
that merged and I was struggling and
I'll since I've been here I've been
doing yoga once a week and I felt like
my body is getting better and most legs
what's the best pose that you do just
laying down the end when you gotta relax
go to sleep
let's see you exhale yeah everything he
goes hurt I know you said you haven't
golfed yet but you said you wanted to
golf and are you gonna be bad don't
worry about it
I love my ball that way
[Applause]
it's just crazy to me that you were able
to really slip through the cracks of
every school how does that happen
a question I ask myself here are those
time it was rough it was times where I
was thinking about just quitting
it was like what I got to do like I felt
like I proved myself against some of the
top teams top players and still nobody
offered me again and how did you
convince yourself to keep going I think
it was more of my parents I mean once
you get down and started questioning
yourself it's hard to get back and my
parents just told me to just keep
working it end up paying off so but if
you could just tell your parents
something about helping you with your
journey what would it be I love I don't
think I can thank them enough the
negative things my dad to say my mom
yelling at him for the negative things
he said how did that tough love from
your dad help you um he probably would
called me overrated say I haven't done
anything yet I think I finally
understood like what he was doing
because he really prepared me for what
was gonna happen I'm like mainly a lot
this year obviously my name blew up so
every away game the fans yelling
overrated my dad told me that yeah like
it doesn't bother me if I if I can tell
you for my dad I can tell you from
anybody
games still not over cuz you hit it game
still on the line let me see your form
before you hit it I know cuz I'm like
you got this so I'm gonna let you play
some fantasy basketball right now if you
could pick any players in the league
current players including yourself who's
on your team well I'll have to go with
me first point guard
I like Paul George to be my - you also
play defense there's a tough decision
for the three I don't know I'll keep
Katie or Bobby Katie because bran he can
make plays but I feel like I can be that
facilitator for this team for the four
rather going green sweet okay my 5ad
everyday that's good
who are you gonna enjoy throwing lobster
the most I'm not team probably athing
today probably be that pick-and-roll you
just throw it any way around around here
to go get it
I was watching an interview when you
reference Drake's lyric like that's
around the time that your idols become
your rivals yeah how does that line
relate to you it's gonna late a lot so
once I get an NBA watching guys that I
grew up watching honestly who been there
in the NBA for a while and stepping on
the same quarters then he's gonna feel
great but at the same time you can't
have no friends on the court which
basketball player though is it gonna be
like it'll take you a minute to say
right this is my opponent I can't like
appreciate them as a basketball player
right now who's that one player
whisperer
yeah my favorite player got a lot of
love for and once I step in those four
lives again against him it's just gonna
be a battle so what have you taken from
his game I just like what he do on the
floor he try to do everything he can to
help her
if it's rebounding the ball making plays
for his teammate or score the ball and
that's kind of how I try to play just do
anything I can help my team win and just
try to play an all-around game for every
guest that I have on the show we do a
take a new segment and that's what we're
gonna do right now okay take me to your
first win in basketball my first year a
you and I played with my dad I think the
most thing I remember about it is when I
coaches I tell them to us to keep our
hands out when we play defense so he
started this lunch aunt called airplane
so like we'll be playing defense
everybody be screaming everything yeah
take me to the inspiration for the
eyebrow cuts oh well my dad had him wear
heels okay that's cool it did look a
look again it's cool and you probably
don't see most people little man I got
to say anyone do you do them on your own
you go to the barber and he does he
actually my dad's a barber so you touch
my hair and do the miles I take me to
playing AAU with Zion Williamson we won
a lot of games it wasn't too many losses
we had so when you guys were playing did
you know the path Sion was going to take
I knew he would be a special talent he
was a rising freshman I was in 10th
grade he was playing up with us and
we're scoring easy against older guy so
I always knew he had an inhale
[Music]
you have called yourself the point guard
shin and a point guard go on first and
then be a draft well most people they
blowing up the point guard ain't saying
I'm arrogant and cocky but what they
don't know is me and my dad and them
been saying since I was playing and
that's just me being humble and
confident at the same time I feel like I
am a top player in this draft but
regardless of where I go first second
third i'ma still be the same John just
try to make an impact on whatever teams
happen
step back John okay he told us all relax
I'm not done yet John Moran on the show
today which by the way we call you JA
but your real name is some Beatrice and
your middle name is jahmiya and that's a
really good job yes honored to be all oh
why we're happy to have you on thank you
[Music]
[Music]
hello guys it is Taylor rooks thank you
so much for watching my show take it
there but now you have to subscribe you
don't want to miss the next interview
and all the fun stuff we're doing on the
YouTube channel so hit that subscribe
button thanks see you guys soon